[Musik]
bis bald gast ist die blm unique dass
sich im ersten moment so anhört als
wollte ich so etwas wie eine
kommunikations ethik formulieren das
möchte ich nicht
ich werde auch keinen philosophischen
vortrag halten weil ich das ja nur als
freizeitbeschäftigung könnte ich bin ja
ein soziologe sondern was ich machen
möchte
das ist ja folgendes und zwar sage ich
zunächst was ich nicht machen möchte ich
halte keinen vortrag der selbst eine
normative perspektive einnimmt zumindest
nicht in der weise dass mich normative
fragen als erste fragen interessieren
und das mag für einen soziologen
vielleicht zunächst eine art ritus sein
damit zu beginn mit solch einem satz
vorträge die mit solch einem satz
beginnen sind meistens auf eine
unaufgeklärte weise normativ und
trotzdem sage ich diesen satz weil ich
auch versuchen möchte weil ich am ende
mit einer normativen intuition dann doch
enden möchte sagen dass ich tatsächlich
mein argument nicht als ein normatives
argument verstehe ich werde auch keine
philosophische perspektive ein nämlich
nicht deshalb weil sozusagen die
fakultäten unterschiedliche sind sondern
weil mein argument explizit kein
philosophisches ist und auf der
empirischen seite die philosophie
vorkommen soll
ich hoffe dass das gelingt und ich
beginne auch nicht mit ethik sondern mit
moral und zwar möchte ich moral
grundlegenden mechanismus der
kommunikation
interessant ist ja wenn man sich als
empirica mit moral fragen beschäftigt
und wir haben mehrere forschungsprojekte
gemacht indem wir uns aus soziologischer
perspektive tatsächlich empirisch dafür
interessieren wie moralische und
ethische kommunikation funktioniert und
in welchen kontexten sie stattfindet ist
jedoch sehr interessant zu sehen dass
die menschen in unterschiedlichen praxis
feldern moralischer handeln und
argumentieren als man das auf den ersten
moment denkt in sehr vielen
handlungsfeldern stellen wir fest dass
vieles von dem was an handlungs
einschränkung funktioniert die erste
soziologische intuition ist die das
soziale ordnung darin besteht
dass menschen nicht alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten die sie haben
auch tatsächlich empirisch in anspruch
nehmen sondern selbst in einer
bestimmten art und weise einschränkung
einschränken einer dieser mechanismen
der einschränkung ist tatsächlich moral
ich verstehe unter moral auch nicht
etwas subjektives tisches in dem sinne
dass es entweder beliebig sei was ein
individuum unter moralischen richtigen
setzen versteht oder geradezu
subjektives tisch in dem sinne dass man
in einer posten und eine postmoderne
relativismus sagen könnte da wir keine
eindeutige gesellschaft zweite moral
haben
klammer auf die frage wer ja noch zu
beantworten ob dieser satz stimmt
klammer zu da wir das nicht haben gibt
es so etwas wie eine beliebigkeit
unterschiedlicher moralische standpunkte
auch das will ich nicht vertreten im
philosophischen sprachgebrauch werde ich
tatsächlich so etwas wie ein objektives
tischen standpunkt von moral formulieren
weil moralische ansprüche stets einen
anspruch auf geltung oder auf gültigkeit
haben wenn ich mit einem moralischen
anspruch irgendwo hingehe dann wäre
dieser moralische anspruch sehr
merkwürdig zu formulieren wenn ich sage
gilt eigentlich nur für mich und ob er
für euch auch gilt ist mir völlig
wurscht dann ist er eigentlich kein
moralischer anspruch sondern er sollte
schon so etwas wie eine pre skript tief
oder zumindest auffordernde idee davon
vermitteln dass man etwas für richtig
und etwas anderes für falsch hält
womöglich sogar etwas für gut und etwas
anderes für böse eine weitere empirische
beobachtung ist zunächst einmal dass es
in dieser gesellschaft keineswegs eine
moralische beliebigkeit gibt es gibt
viele sätze viele moralische ansprüche
moralische setzte die oder ich
vielleicht anders rum viele normative
setzte die in dieser gesellschaft nicht
anschlussfähig wären es ist zum beispiel
unglaublich schwer in unseren
moralischen diskursen menschen danach
einzuteilen ob sie moralisch angemessene
oder moralisch zu behandelnde
entitäten sind oder nicht wir würden
wahrscheinlich in vielem von dem was
unsere moralischen intuition angeht
immer davon ausgehen dass menschen als
menschen adressaten für moralische
ansprüche sind und es fällt sehr schwer
zu sagen dass menschen die größer oder
kleiner sind die ein volles haupthaar
haben oder gar keines das kommt in der
empirie vor wie sie sehen die männer
oder frauen sind die ausländer oder
inländer sind die klug oder dumm sind
die soziologen oder philosophen sind was
auch immer prinzipiell unterschiedlich
moralisch zu ich weiß auf englisch sagt
man treten wie heißt das dann auf
deutsche behandeln ja also das hört sich
doof an zu behandeln sind ja und dafür
muss es ja bestimmte gründe geben wenn
man und zwar auch soziologische gründe
wenn man nicht von vorneherein diese art
und weise die es schwierig macht dass
wir menschen nach unterschiedlichen
moralischen standards zumindest in
moralischer oder ethischer kommunikation
behandeln dies sozusagen als eine
selbstverständlichkeit annehmen weil es
wäre ja auch etwas anderes möglich und
wir kennen aus der eigenen geschichte
genug beispiele dass man das auch in
gesellschaften entsprechend durchsetzen
kann so dass war nur vorrede ich fange
an und zwar möchte ich sieben schritte
einhalten wie sich das gehört
und davon werden sechs argumente sein
und am ende eine normative intuition
stehen
ich beginne am zunächst mit einer
soziologischen idee einer kommunikation
zur interaktions theorie wenn wie mein
programm ja formuliert hat ich vorhabe
moral an der grund an der grundlegenden
form von kommunikation nachzuweisen oder
umgekehrt die moral als einen
grundlegenden mechanismus von
kommunikation zu beschreiben dann muss
ich zunächst einmal sagen was ich unter
kommunikation verstehe ich stelle mich
da selbst in die tradition
unterschiedlicher soziologische theorie
man könnte alfried schütz nennen man
könnte
hoffmann vor allem den pragmatismus
georgia that needs und in meinem fall
natürlich die soziologische
systemtheorie im anschluss an die classe
lumen die alle von einem grund theorem
ausgehen nämlich von dem was wir in der
soziologie das theorem der doppelten
kontingents nennen doppelte kontingents
ist eine ist ein versuchsaufbau unter
doppelter kontingents verstehen wir die
situation dass sich alter und ego
begegnen und alter und ego ihr verhalten
jeweils von ego und alter abhängig
machen und diese situation eigentlich
den wärme tod sterben müsste wenn sie
sich nicht sozusagen von vorneherein
asymmetrie sieren und es zu einer
anschluss handlung kommt also wenn ich
mein verhalten von meinem gegenüber
abhängig mache und das gegenüber sein
verhalten von mir abhängig macht dann
kann zunächst einmal nichts passieren in
gesellschaftlichen situationen kommt
aber diese reine situation doppelter
kontingents nicht vor
wir befinden uns immer schon in
asymmetrischen verhältnissen also wenn
zum beispiel jemand an so ein podium
tritt dann wird von ihm erwartet dass er
anfängt zu reden was er sagt es zunächst
mal wurscht wenn jemand vor einem podium
sitzt wie sie dann wird zunächst einmal
davon ausgegangen dass er schweigt
worüber er schreibt es zunächst einmal
forscht und diese asymmetrische
situation führt dazu dass und das wäre
die idee dieser system theoretischen
variante ein drittes entsteht nämlich
kommunikation die alter und ego jeweils
in anspruch nimmt jeweils in anspruch
nimmt würde bedeuten dass ein
kommunikationssystem in der zeit
entsteht in dem alter und ego jeweils
durch äußerungen herausgefordert werden
sich innerhalb dieses systems zu bewegen
das alte und ego nicht das gleiche wie
die psychischen systeme sind usw
das lasse ich hier draußen das ist eine
simple modell ein einfaches modell von
kommunikation dass kommunikation als
etwas drittes ansieht dass vor allem
darauf kommt es mir jetzt an in der
interaktion immer mit einem gegenüber zu
tun hat mit einem gegenüber das als
alter ego oder ego oder alter
zu sehen ist diese interaktions theorie
geht davon aus dass strukturaufbau
dadurch passiert dass unterschiedliche
äußerungen sich wechselseitig
ermöglichen dass sie also eine struktur
entwickeln müssen in denen in der
anschlussfähigkeit entsteht
man kann das ganz einfach erklären an
empirischen beispielen sie können
krisenkommunikation machen das heißt sie
können an jemanden herantreten und etwas
sagen was der nicht verstehen kann der
wird womöglich darauf reagieren indem er
sagt das verstehe ich nicht
und schon ist kommunikation gelungen
also kaum gelungene kommunikation ist
nicht die übertragung einer information
auf ein gegenüber und dann um dann zu
messen ob der kanal ein angemessener
kanal war oder nicht sondern gelungene
kommunikation wäre nach einem
mathematischen genetischen
kommunikations begriff die selektivität
die sich im nacheinander kommunikative
ereignisse ergibt sie können das gleiche
auch sprach pragmatisch mit habermas
rekonstruieren da kämen ein paar andere
notationen vor aber prinzipiell ist es
etwas ähnliches so dass belasse ich bei
diesen andeutungen
zweiter punkt von 7 ein sehr wichtiger
wichtig zumindest für mein argument der
zweite punkt sagt dass man aus dieser
theorie der kommunikation eine theorie
der moral reduzieren kann
das problem doppelter kontingents
besteht darin dass jeder ego und alter
ego ist und weiß dass er für den anderen
alter ego ist also eine mehrstufige form
der wechselseitigen zurechnung die ihm
übrigens kein übrigens nicht subjekt
theoretisch im sinne sozusagen selbst
transparenz von alter und ego zu
verstehen ist sondern die komplizierte
situation beschreibt wie alter und ego
in kommunikationssystemen gewissermaßen
in anspruch genommen werden und diese
mehrstufige relation ist so komplex dass
es zur kommunikation kaum kommen könnte
wenn das alter und ego jeweils
transparent gemacht
werden müsste das können sie
rekonstruieren mit schütz mit miet mit
berger luckmann mit goßmann und auch in
der systemtheorie gibt unterschiedliche
begriffe dafür aber sie finden überall
beschreibungen dieser komplexen
situation die sich dann empirisch
weniger komplex auflösen muss die frage
ist wie wird sie für sich ego und alte
und alter ego innerhalb des
kommunikations zusammenhangs integriert
george abbott mit hat dafür die schöne
formel des roll taking entwickelt
rotating würde bedeuten das ist übrigens
heute von wahrnehmungs physiologen und
hirnforschern letztlich bestätigt worden
peking würde bedeuten dass ein
kommunikativer akt von ego sich immer
schon aus der perspektive von alter
wahrnimmt und daraus sozusagen sowohl
die motive als auch die selektivität
entsteht in der ein sprecher in einer
bestimmten art und weise funktioniert
also man könnte sagen es wäre
außerordentlich schwer für mich diesen
vortrag hier zu halten wenn sie hier
nicht setzen obwohl sie gerade nichts
tun außer dass sie eine
benutzeroberfläche vorzeigen die so
aussieht als würden sie mir zu hören
also stellen sie sich vor man würde hier
alleine stehen das wäre pathologisches
verhalten wahrscheinlich dass ich
alleine hier stehen würde einen vortrag
halten und ich so einer situation wäre
wo ich ja gar nicht unmittelbar auf
ihren response bin sondern davon ausgehe
dass der vortrag nur funktioniert wenn
roll taking da ist das hier ein publikum
sitzt das setzte die soziologischer
natur sind die man eigentlich nicht
verstehen kann zumindest so behandelt
dass es so aussieht als wäre es ein
konsistentes argument und normalisierung
strategien in sozialen situationen
laufen wir auch so dass wir unglaublich
lange brauchen bis wir tatsächlich
sowohl erstens vor uns selbst und die
nächste stufe dann wäre dann vor den
anderen feststellen dass kommunikation
nicht gelungen ist wenn man das mal
empirisch rekonstruieren will muss man
auch wissenschaftliche tagungen fahren
da kann man das sehr schön sehen dass
die leute bis drei tage über dinge
geredet reden und alter und ego jeweils
unterschiedliche vorstellung davon haben
was ego und alter gemeint haben könnten
und diese empirische zugang zur
kommunikation würde gelungene
kommunikation schon daran erkennen dass
es weitergeht nun ist die frage ob
dieses kommen komplizierte system von
kommunikation oder andersrum dieses
komplizierte system von kommunikation
kann empirisch letztlich in dieser
komplexität nicht bearbeitet werden es
müssen also kurzformen etabliert werden
durch die wir in der lage sind in
solchen situationen zu orientieren
george abbott mit schlägt wie ich schon
gesagt habe dass roll taking vor also
letztlich die bestätigung dessen was ich
tue über die erwartung der erwartung
meines gegenübers in der formulierung
von niklas luhmann an einem frühen
aufsatz aus den 70er jahren wird
vorgeschlagen dass diese vereinfachung
ohne eine dieser vereinfachungen achtung
sein können
die achtung vor dem anderen also achtung
würde ja immer bedeuten dass ich zum
beispiel bestimmte sprechakte die
riskant sind und sprechakte sind immer
riskant weil ich nicht weiß wie darauf
reagiert wird wenn man unter risiko
versteht dass man selber nicht
kalkulieren kann welche art von schaden
durch eine eigene entscheidung
hergestellt wird also wenn sozusagen der
riskante sprecher akt trotzdem möglich
ist weil ich davon ausgehe dass ein
sprecher den sie womöglich nicht
erwartet haben trotzdem auf ihre achtung
stößt also wenn ich davon ausgehen würde
das ein argument dass sie für falsch
halten von ihnen respektiert wird mit
dem satz du bist ein schuft da würde ich
dieses argument wahrscheinlich nicht so
leicht gebrauchen können
und wir können eigentlich in interaktion
situationen fast überall wahrnehmen dass
sie nur funktioniert wenn das was
passiert nicht sofort in missachtung
rumschlägt also stellen sich eine
situation vor in dem sie mit dem risiko
umgehen müssen dass alles was sie tut
sofort in missachtung umschlägt das
können sie mit empirisch gibt es
situationen dafür der rassismus ist
dafür ein sehr schönes beispiel so ein
schönes beispiel ist zynisch also ein
beredtes beispiel
also im rassismus könnte man sagen sie
können nicht davon absehen dass ihr
gegenüber ein weißer ist oder ein
schwarzer ist und damit wird jeder
sprech aktion doppel codiert das selbst
sendet das richtige sagt
das noch ein anlass für missachtung ist
weil es sicher eine besonders perfide
strategie handelt dass diejenigen die
schwarzen und endlich ja gar nicht in
der lage sind wichtige argumente zu
bringen sich so perfide verhalten dass
sie richtige argumente simulieren die so
aussehen als wäre ein weißer so
funktioniert rassismus in diesem
sozusagen sehr einfachen operativen
zusammenhängen so meistens gehen wir
davon aus
und meistens gelingt das auch dass das
gegenüber mit achtung reagiert mit
achtung das wäre das argument achtung
und nicht missachtung wäre so etwas wie
eine minimale grundlegende moral
innerhalb der kommunikation weil
missachtung ja immer bedeuten würde dass
man letztlich in eine moral schema das
gegenteil voraussetzt also immer musst
du dich diese extremen beispiele nennen
oder sehen an denen man sehr schön
erkennen kann dass etwa
minderheitengruppen die müssen dass gar
keine minderheiten seien in bestimmten
situationen automatisch missachtung
erfahren also missachtung muss übrigens
gar nicht heißen dass man dem anderen
unmittelbar sagte sei ein schuft sondern
dass der sprecher
letztlich nicht als das angesehen wird
als dass er eigentlich als der
eigentlich auftaucht also schon die
tatsache dass wir heute in situationen
in denen es keine frauen gibt zum
beispiel den vorständen von unternehmen
davon ausgehen müssen dass eine frau in
einem vorstand eines unternehmens eine
information ist das ja eine merkwürdige
situation ist weil es sich auch um einen
menschen handelt das ist anthropologisch
inzwischen erwiesen wir sozusagen schon
die tatsache dass jemand sagt das sagen
sie natürlich weil sie eine frau sind
bereits eine moralische codierung der
kommunikation darstellt und das gilt
übrigens genauso für einen extremen
gender diskurs der danach sucht dass das
was durch männer formuliert ist
automatisch nicht das sein kann was man
eigentlich erwarten müsste innerhalb
einer ganz bestimmten form von
kommunikation gucken sich marc tweets an
in den sozusagen die die
die herrschende presse rekonstruieren
indem man sozusagen männer quoten in der
süddeutschen zeitung rekonstruiert und
sich gar nicht dafür interessiert ob
diese männer quatsch oder nicht quatsch
geschrieben haben das kommt ja beides
vor auch empirisch erwiesen sondern dass
es sich um männer handelt also männer
frauen schwarze große kleine das wäre
sozusagen etwas was anlass für achtung
oder missachtung ist oder sie können
jedes beliebige andere beispiel nehmen
sobald missachtet wird
stockt die kommunikation
daraus kann man schließen sobald
geachtet wird geht die kommunikation
weiter sie werden feststellen dass das
was ich hier als grundlegende minimal
moral von kommunikation versuche zu
beschreiben von zwei sehr wichtigen
dingen abhängig ist von zwei
theoretischen überlegungen die eine
theoretische überlegung ist tatsächlich
das funktions oder entschuldigung dass
kommunikationssysteme vor allem am
funktionieren ihrer selbst interessiert
sind und interessiert sind ist natürlich
ein theoretisch problematischer ausdruck
weil die natürlich nicht interessiert
sind wie man üblicherweise mit zentralen
nervensystem ausgestattete entitäten
ansieht sondern interessiert würde
heißen ihre selektivität geht in die
richtung dass es weitergehen könnte
und achtung ist eine ganz bestimmte form
in der man sozusagen personen so
inkludiert dass es tatsächlich
weitergeht empirisch können sie sehr
schön sehen das in dieser form etwa
gruppen moral in den unterschiedlichen
gruppen der gesellschaft entstehen
können in denen implizit relativ klar
ist was richtig und was falsch oder
sogar was gut und was böse sein kann
diese art von moral wäre sozusagen eine
moral die womöglich gar nicht explizit
formuliert werden muss und dass
vielleicht beunruhigende an der
geschichte ist dass zu solchen moore
ahlen womöglich auch das ist natürlich
jetzt kein nativer moral begriff dass zu
solchen oralen auch dinge gehören können
diese normativ problematisch finden aber
ich glaube es ist ganz hilfreich
zunächst einmal einen solchen moral
begriff zu formulieren
es wäre nun völlig falsch zu glauben
dass diese art von moral im sinne
letztlich der gelingens generator von
kommunikation ist die einzige form ist
kommunikation am laufen zu halten
es gibt auch noch andere vor allem der
modernen gesellschaft in die äquivalente
zum beispiel geld macht wahrheit oder
auch das recht also eine
zivilisatorische errungenschaft des
geldes und des handels besteht unter
anderem darin dass der wert des geldes
als kommunikationsmedium als symbolisch
generalisiert des kommunikationsmedium
sich unter anderem davon unabhängig
machen kann wer zahlt also der wert
eines 20 euro scheins wird nicht dadurch
korrumpiert dass der 20 euro scheint von
einem soziologen bezahlt wurde sondern
dieses medium ist so stabil geld ist
nicht stabil geld ist hochgradig
instabil aber das medium ist stabil im
hinblick darauf dass die zurechnung dem
medium gegenüber erfolgt und nicht der
person das gleiche gilt übrigens auch
für wissenschaftliche wahrheit
wir würden wissenschaftliche wahrheit
als etwas ansehen was letztlich
unabhängig von dem gelten sollte der das
argument vorbringt habermas wundervolle
formulierung des zwanglosen zwangs des
besseren arguments wäre so ein hinweis
darauf dass ich sogar einem argument
folgend würde das von uli schroth stand
und
also muss ich sagen dass wir jetzt
übertrieben hat aber ja also sogar würde
heißen dass das letztlich die
gesellschaft auch andere medien
entwickelt als diese achtung oder
missachtung personen gegenüber die
anstehen anschluss von kommunikation
wahrscheinlicher zu machen
für das recht gilt das zum teil auch das
wie justitia blind darstellen ist ein
zeichen für die moralische anonymität
des rechts machen moralisch anonymität
heißt nicht dass das recht unmoralisch
oder moralisch sei das ist es nicht
sondern dass die praxis des rechts von
der person ab sieht um der person
gegenüber gerecht zu werden
achtung bedeutet übrigens auch nicht
konsens oder norman konformität sondern
achtung wäre tatsächlich wenn das stimmt
mein argument dass es sich um einen
sozusagen funktionsträger für
anschlussfähigkeit handelt auch möglich
wenn wir distanz haben also ein dissens
über sogar normative fragen wäre
durchaus kompatibel mit einem
achtungserfolg gegen über das würden wir
zum beispiel bei der rekonstruktion von
interkulturalität oder interreligiösen
dialogen oder auch innerhalb sagen wir
mal normativer diskurse formulieren dass
wir auf keinen fall davon ausgehen dass
wir etwa in einem normativen konflikt
stets davon ausgehen müssen dass der
andere der eine andere normative
intuition oder sogar ein normatives
argument hat automatisch missachtet
werden müsste und dass ich jetzt sage
ich ist wiederum keine normativer satz
sondern eine möglichkeit die empirisch
vorkommt achtung ist also der grund der
moral und nicht umgekehrt moral immer
schon begründet und die bedingungen von
achtung machen letztlich die moral einer
gesellschaft aus sind für den soziologen
ist es vielleicht interessant so was an
kleinen empirischen situationen zu
rekonstruieren
es ist für uns unglaublich leicht über
leute her zu ziehen die nicht im raum
sind dann kommen die reihen und ihnen
das gleichzeitig ins gesicht zu sagen
fällt uns schwerer
man könnte das auch psychologisch mit zu
formen von peinlichkeit oder ähnlichem
formulieren aber es ist außerordentlich
kompliziert über jemanden herzuziehen
der da ist weil wir sozusagen
automatisch missachtung kommunizieren
würden was die anschlussfähigkeit von
kommunikation viel komplizierter macht
deshalb sind die leute ja auch bisweilen
wenn sie etwa an den rassismus denken in
anwesenheit von schwarzen zum beispiel
tolerant und sobald die raus sind fallen
sätze die nie fallen könnten wenn sie da
wären all das ist eine empirische frage
und die frage die natürlich den
soziologen interessiert ist dann auch
wie gehen wir eigentlich mit differenten
moralvorstellungen um also das was ich
gesagt habe könnte natürlich zur folge
haben dass es zum beispiel
unterschiedliche binnen und gruppen
moore aalen gibt die sind übrigens auch
kompatibel womöglich mit mit einer
stärker geteilten normativen moral in
der gesellschaft aber trotzdem gibt es
unterschiedliche gruppen moral und
gesellschaftlichen gesellschaften
entwickeln sicher entsprechend wenn sie
sich etwa angucken
allein die geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland wie wir mit moralischen
pluralismus in unterschiedlichen milieus
heute umgehen können im vergleich zu den
50er jahren
dann würden wir ja keineswegs sagen dass
die gesellschaft weniger moral enthält
und vor allem weniger geteilte moral
enthält sondern wir haben vielleicht
sogar eine moral der toleranz die davon
ausgeht dass wir dinge die wir normativ
falsch halten für moralisch zumindest
soweit angemessen halten
dass wir den anderen nur soweit
missachten dass kommunikation nicht zu
stark gestört wird
wie geht man also mit differenz um eine
form
das ist übrigens eine formulierung von
von niklas luhmann die ich übernehme ist
takkt takkt setzt voraus eine art von
differenziertheit zwischen sagen und
meinen unterscheiden zu können und
kommunikation weiter möglich zu machen
also packt wäre etwas was zum beispiel
das wissen die anwesenden professoren im
raum prüfer brauchen wenn eine prüfung
nicht gut läuft also sozusagen
da sitzt jemand und ist offenkundig das
ist ganz und technisch sagen zu doof und
wir haben einen eid geschworen dass wir
der wahrheit verpflichtet sind würden es
aber nie sagen sondern sind dann
taktvoll und taktvoll werden wir indem
wir davon absehen weitere sätze zu sagen
die achtung und missachtung in anspruch
nehmen würden das wäre eine form mit
moralischer differenz umzugehen oder mit
solchen konflikten umzugehen eine andere
ist die andere extrem form nämlich der
moralismus mit dritten also wir könnten
zum beispiel wir sind meistens
vergleichsweise friedlich wenn wir den
leuten gegenüber sind und können dann
mit dritten eine starke moral fliegen
die den anderen als missachtens wert
beschreibt das machen wir auch den
ganzen tag in dem wir sozusagen
moralisch ziemlich genau wissen welche
gruppen zu achten sind und welche zu
missachten sind so dritter punkt
diese idee von moral die ich jetzt
gerade entwickelt habe ist kompatibel
mit asymmetrie wir haben ja heute eine
idee das moralisch kommen gleich dazu
vor allem etwas symmetrisches ist oder
falsch dass die eti sierung von fragen
dazu führen soll dass wir auf augenhöhe
symmetrisch miteinander umgehen wird das
gleich erklären was ich damit meine
diese art von moral die ich gerade
beschrieben haben
das nicht eine art von moral sondern das
verständnis von moral ist durchaus mit
asymmetrie kompatibel das muss gesagt
werden weil das für ein argument später
sehr wichtig sein wird zum beispiel mit
der asymmetrie des verhältnisses von
experten oder professionellen und laien
ich glaube das verhältnis von von von
angehörigen von professionalisierten
berufen und laien ist eines der
wichtigsten könnte sagen schlüssel
verhältnisse für die entstehung der
modernen gesellschaft denken sie an das
verhältnis von ärzten und patienten das
verhältnis von priestern und gläubigen
das verhältnis von lehrpersonal und
schülern auf unterschiedlichen ebenen
das verhältnis von richtern und
konfigurieren parteien das verhältnis
von meistern und gesellen
dieses verhältnis ist meistens ein
verhältnis das asyl ähnlich meistens ist
ein verhältnis das asymmetrisch gebaut
ist und in dieser asymmetrie ist eine
bestimmte form von moral eingebaut die
die asymmetrie achtet und zwar in der
weise dass professionell handelnde vor
allem als gute gründe lieferanten dienen
man könnte fast sagen dass die dass
diejenigen die sozusagen in der lage
sind das richtige zu vertreten zb der
patient der arzt dem patienten gegenüber
also parente gesagt torque parsons hat
in seiner in seiner soziologie seiner
profession soziologie wundervoll
beschrieben dass der arzt eine der
ersten sozial figuren in der
gesellschaft war in der lage war
jemanden der im run der gesellschaft
über ihm steht sätze zu sagen wie es
auch nicht so viel
sonst wirst du das jahr nicht überleben
jeder andere wäre dafür geköpft worden
der professionelle ist in der lage dem
anderen einen satz zu sagen er soll
etwas bestimmtes tun weil er bessere
gründe kennt als er selber zum
professionellen gehört auch noch die
brutalität dass ein besseres argument
ein besseres argument ist als ein
schlechteres argument das ist brutal
ja das ist hochgradig asymmetrisch das
ist auch das was im prinzip den impetus
von wissenschaftlicher kommunikation
ausmacht wir würden ja immer sagen ein
besseres argument ist ein besseres
argument und schlechteres argument ist
ein schlechteres argument und diese
asymmetrie muss man aushalten können im
übrigen gehört zur professionalität auch
dann dazu dass wenn ich sage mein
argument ist besser als das des kollegen
oder der kollegin damit die kollegin
wieder missachtet noch geachtet wird
sondern wir innerhalb eines wahrheit'
codes in unterwegs sind der sich davon
unabhängig machen sollte tut er
natürlich empirisch nicht immer aber das
wäre im prinzip die idee dieser
geschichte also nochmal moral ist
kompatibel mit asymmetrie und die
figuren der professionellen die ja
interessanterweise mehr können als ihr
fach also ein mediziner ist ja nur
jemand der in der lage ist biochemische
zusammenhänge von so merkwürdigen
entitäten wie unseren körpern oder auch
unseren psychen in irgendeiner weise zu
beschreiben ein arztes jemand der in der
lage ist asymmetrisch mit in seiner
klientel zu zu diskutieren ich zu
diskutieren entschuldigen zu
kommunizieren und der klientel zu sagen
anzunehmen dass seine diagnose die ist
die ihn zu einem anderen leben zu einer
therapie oder was auch immer führen soll
und ist es kein wunder dass dieses
verhältnis dieses asymmetrische
verhältnis meistens sehr stark
aufgeladen wird durch so etwas wie moral
ja es gibt die moral des fastens hat das
auch beschrieben sozusagen der
gemeinwohlorientierung
professionalisierte berufe also sie
können das einen kleinen begriffen noch
sehen warum bekommt ein arzt eigentlich
ein honorar
warum ist ein fehler eines arztes ein
kunstfehler
warum ist der arzt jemand der einer
schweigepflicht unterliegt zumindest in
den meisten fällen die muss rechtlich
aufgehoben werden das liegt alles
sozusagen daran dass diese asymmetrie
selbst eine moralische bedeutung ich
breche das jetzt hier ab
vierter punkt vierter der dritte war das
mit der mit der asyl betrieb ich habe
richtig mitgezählt sagt wir nicht mehr
gezählt steht auf meinem zettel im
zählen habe ich es nicht so aber das
klappt vierter punkt also ein
gesellschafts theoretisches argument was
wir beobachten können ist dass das was
ich gerade als moral dargestellt habe in
komplexen gesellschaften zumindest nicht
als gesamt moral von gesellschaft sich
erweisen kann weil gesellschaft
keineswegs auf interaktionen das heißt
auf unmittelbare sichtbarkeit aus ist
alle beispiel die ich bis jetzt gebracht
habe sind beispiele die mit der
sichtbarkeit von personen wechselseitig
zu tun haben also das beispiel was ich
gesagt habe ist es leichter ein rassist
zu sein wenn das objekt meines rassismus
nicht vor mir sitzt übrigens kann man
das in der empirischen sozialforschung
sehr schön sehen die meisten
antisemitismus gibt es in den gegenden
wo sie niemals einen juden treffen
werden
das ist
absurd eigentlich aber es ist dann nicht
mehr absurd weil sie sozusagen wenn sie
gerade der jude ist sozusagen ein
wunderbares beispiel dafür wie fremdheit
da dieser ja nicht wirklich fremd ist
durch komplizierte mechanismen erzeugt
werden muss werden der vor ihnen sitzt
können sie nicht erkennen dass er einer
ist also es ist leicht ein antisemit zu
sein wenn keiner da ist es ist leichter
für richard wagner über das judentum in
der musik zu schreiben wenn mendelssohn
bartholdy schon tot ist
zu lebzeiten hat er sich das nicht
getraut selbst warten da hat sich das
und zwar explizit nicht getraut wir
selber auch gesagt hat weil mendelssohn
bartholdy die wunderbarste musik
geschrieben hat die für wagner selber
wichtig war und man in gerade in dem
wunderbaren dieser musik sehen konnte
wie perfide der jude ist dass er
simuliert er könne richtige kunst machen
das ist das also das ist sozusagen genau
genau diese diese argumentation über die
diese form von moralisierung
funktioniert so also alles immer mit
sichtbarkeit zu beschreiben eine moderne
gesellschaft geht auch schon vor
hochkulturen aber ich will es für
moderne gesellschaften beschreiben gilt
das natürlich nicht wir haben eine stark
sich aus differenzierende gesellschaft
diese ausdifferenzieren die gesellschaft
bringt unterschiedliche funktions
systeme unterschiedliche arten und
weisen hervor wie kommunikation sich
selber ordnet sie bringt
unterschiedliche formen hervor der das
der generierung von erfolg in einem
ökonomischen system in einem politischen
system in einem wissenschaftssystem
selbst religion differenziert sich von
bestimmten funktionen die sie vorher
hatte weg die familien kommunikation
wird zu einer die sich von öffentlicher
kommunikation viel stärker zu
unterscheiden beginnt als vorher
und was jetzt für mein argument
außerordentlich wichtig ist ist dass
diese unterschiedlichen funktions
systeme vor allem ein problem erzeugen
nämlich unmoral
und moral würde heißen eine gefahr von
unmoral deshalb weil wenn geld
tatsächlich so funktioniert dass die
anschlussfähigkeit des geldes von der
ansicht des gegenübers und damit von
achtung und missachtung unabhängig wird
dann kann gerade im geldverkehr der
andere auf eine kunstvoll
zivilisatorische weise betrogen werden
ohne dass ich ihn als person meinen muss
das gleiche gilt übrigens auch für die
folgen politischer herrschaft politische
herrschaft wird so stark
institutionalisiert dass sie sich von
einer bestimmten form von moral
unabhängig machen kann weil sie
sozusagen die mit den machterhalt selbst
als möglichkeit ansehen kann sich zu
erhalten und die geschichte der moderne
ist voll von options- steigerung des
politischen in denen tatsächlich die
macht der einzige sinn der machtausübung
gewesen ist
die katastrophen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts nenne ich eine option
steigerung des politischen die
diktaturen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
hatten vor allem damit zu tun alle
bereiche der gesellschaft mit macht zu
überziehen und keineswegs sozusagen
politische inhalte durchzusetzen weil
sie als politische inhalte einen
moralischen wert haben das schreckliche
an revolutionen ist dass sie meistens
mit hoch moralischen intentionen
beginnen und am ende nur noch das
problem haben ihre macht sichern zu
müssen das was wir empirisch ja
tatsächlich
tatsächlich kennen das noch absurdere
daran ist dass es bisweilen die
beherrschten sind die diese moral da
noch stärker hervorheben als die
herrschenden selber das kann man also
für die endphase etwa dass
nationalsozialismus in deutschland
vergleichsweise gut zeigen dass die
zyniker tatsächlich oben saß noch nicht
unten ja also die leute runden haben
sozusagen nur an den endsieg geglaubt
bisweilen den die oben aus technischen
gründen formuliert haben um wenigstens
noch soweit weiter zu machen zu können
dass sie bis zur militärischen
niederlage die ja absehbar war
an der macht bleiben können und das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch für das geld
wir können das sehr schön daran erkennen
dass wir das geld inzwischen zu den
geldverkehr selbst von personen
unabhängig machen wenn sie an den
computerhandel an börsen denken dann ist
der computerhandel an börsen weder
moralisch noch unmoralisch sondern
amoralisch war der sozusagen noch nicht
einmal personen wechselseitig erkennen
kann das heißt diese zahlungsvorgänge
wissen noch nicht einmal sie können noch
nicht mal die intention haben etwas
ökonomisch unangenehm ist in der
gesellschaft vor zu bringen weil sie gar
keine intention haben können sondern nur
ein algorithmus sind dafür hat und jetzt
max weber schon vor 100 jahren in einem
wundervollen aufsatz über die börse
gewarnt wo er gesagt hat das verrückte
an der schnellen börse ist vor allem
dass das geld der sinn des geldes ist
und wir gar nicht wissen was wir damit
tun so wenn das stimmt was ich gesagt
habe und ich gehe davon aus dass er
stimmt dann kann man sehr schön sehen
dass es schwieriger wird das was in
diesen funktions systemen passiert die
sich vor allem dafür ausdifferenziert
haben besonders effiziente formen zu
bilden und die katastrophen und krisen
der moderne hängt vor allem damit
zusammen dass diese unterschiedlichen
funktions systeme wenig stopp regeln in
sich selbst gesehen haben wenn man das
normativ formulieren können wir sagen
dass es schwierig war moral in diese
formen einzubauen wird man empirisch
trotzdem feststellen dass auch ein
ausdifferenziertes systeme in ihrem
konkreten verkehr von personen immer so
etwas wie sozial moralische formen
ausgebildet haben das am besten
erforscht ist das für den sogenannten
ehrbaren kaufmann
der ehrbare kaufmann als eine sozial
figur ist sozusagen einer also die kommt
als sozial figur ja nur vor weil es
unglaublich schwierig ist auf einem
markt air bar zu bleiben und die leute
ist trotzdem tun und zwar deshalb dass
beginnen die ökonomen inzwischen mit
ihrem homo oeconomicus auch zu
rekonstruieren die haben das größte
problem altruismus darzustellen weil
sich das in einer ökonomie die sozusagen
einen nur eine zeit stelle kennt
letztlich nicht rekonstruieren lässt
wenn man aber davon ausgeht dass er mit
der gleichen person übermorgen auch noch
geschäfte machen muss da muss ich mir
angucken was das für eine person ist
schon um nur zu erkennen dass es
dieselbe ist und sobald man das erkennt
kommt der mechanismus von achtung und
missachtung wieder zur geltung
ob es tatsächlich gelingt ja das sage
ich jetzt nicht diese ausdifferenzierung
der gesellschaft produziert also
moralische probleme in der weise dass
vieles was in der gesellschaft passiert
sich diese moralischen codierung
eigentlich entzieht und wir uns fragen
müssen wie es denn eigentlich um die
moralische verfassung der gesamten
gesellschaft bestimmt ist
wenn es so etwas geben kann in einen
einfachen gesellschaften com gab es das
natürlich durch die konvention sozusagen
einer form von wechselseitigkeit und ich
würde jetzt wenn ich jetzt mal ein paar
in these etwas normatives sagen darf
sagen dass wir wenn wir das normativ
rekonstruieren feststellen können dass
das sozusagen sozial formen die auf
anwesenheit aufgebaut sind tatsächlich
auch so eine art von wechselseitigkeit
erzeugen die womöglich sogar gegen die
intentionen der handelnden so etwas wie
eine moral erzeugen die zumindest in
diesen jeweiligen cosmo wenn es so etwas
geben kann universalistische sind aber
das ist sozusagen nur in parente gesagt
wie weit es sich also mit der gesamt
moral der gesellschaft
ich komme mir zu meinem fünften punkt
zur gesamt moral der gesellschaft sagt
vor allem die wissenschaft etwas nämlich
die ethik die ethik nachdem wird sagen
üblichen sprachgebrauch eine
wissenschaftliche theorie des
moralischen oder nicht eine
wissenschaftliche theorie sondern ein
wissenschaftliche auseinandersetzung
unterschiedlicher natur
mit dem moralischen setzt sozusagen dort
an wo man moral innerhalb der
gesellschaft nicht mehr so einfach
wieder findet er philosophische fragen
war wurde zwischen sitte und
sittlichkeit unterscheiden
er würde unterscheiden zwischen alltags
weltlichen gründungs formen und
rationalen oder wissenschaftlichen
begründung formen wobei rationalität für
den alltag ja durchaus
nicht geleugnet werden muss aber
sozusagen mann aus der perspektive einer
wissenschaftlichen beobachtung das heißt
also eine eines dieser funktion systeme
rekonstruiert die welt als wäre sie eine
gründe welt das sage ich übrigens nicht
kritisch sondern die frage ist was soll
denn wissenschaft sonst tun als genau
dass sie rekonstruiert also die welt als
sei sie so konsistent das darin
moralische urteile vor allem dem
mechanismus folgen den wir aus der
wissenschaft kennen nämlich dass das
bessere argument das bessere argument
des schlechteren argument ist auch das
sage ich wir uns nicht kritik sondern
als beschreibung ethik ist theoretischer
operation ist wissenschaftliche
operation und etabliert sich sozusagen
dort wo man gründe dafür finden muss wie
die dinge wären würden sie auf gründen
basieren die darüber ihn vielleicht
finden wir irgendwann mal mögen die
möglichkeit über ihren satz zu
diskutieren hier sicherlich jetzt nicht
den sie mal geschrieben haben in diesem
reclam bändchen eine vollständig in sich
konsistente lebensform produziert keine
begründung probleme und das da wir
empirisch wissen dass es keine
vollständig konsistente lebensformen
gibt wäre ja die interessante frage was
denn einig die differenz ist zwischen
sozusagen dann dieser wissenschaftlichen
beobachtung und der alltags weltlichen
unordnung und es ist ganz interessant
und das trifft natürlich nicht nur sie
sondern das trifft eigentlich gibt dass
die geschäftsgrundlage der
philosophischen ethik dass sie zunächst
bei die welt rekonstruieren muss als sei
sie eine gründe welt um dann algorithmen
bereitstellen zu können indem man
normative fragen klären kann
und es ist ganz wichtig dass wird
nämlich oftmals vergessen vor allem auch
in der anwendung von ethik vergessen
dass die welt eben nicht keine gründe
welt ist sondern unterschiedliche man
könnte sagen ordnungsprinzip in der
gesellschaft wirken in der soziologie
macht wird auf der fehler gemacht dann
zu glauben die ethik sei wirkungslos
das ist dann nur ein
urteilt auch dem eigenen fach gegenüber
zu glauben dass wenn alle bankvorstände
parteivorstände kanzler ämter und von
mir aus universitätsleitungen besser in
gesellschaftstheorie gebildet wären wäre
die welt besser ich kann es sehr
eindeutig und authentisch sagen sie wäre
es nicht ja weil es sich um völlig
unterschiedliche formen der welt
erzeugung handelt und das ist uns auch
in der differenz ich höre dann damit auf
hat das nichts mit postmoderne oder so
was zu tun dass man unterschiedliche
formen der welt erzeugung nebeneinander
sieht so das hat etwas mit der
differenzierung der gesellschaft in
unterschiedliche funktionen zu tun
die eti sierung der moral durch eine
philosophische gründe ethik und ich
lasse völlig außer acht jetzt dass das
viele der sätze nicht in gleicher form
vereine die ontologische oder eine
tugend ethik gelten und dass man
interessante fragen von konsument
concord sequenzielles tischer natur
nicht konsequenz ist ischer natur
unterscheiden müsste
und so weiter und so weiter auch die
frage ob moralische tatsachen genauso
tatsachen sind wie andere tatsachen die
in der theoretischen welt zu beobachten
sind das lasse ich alles weg sondern ich
versuche zunächst zu beobachten dass die
eti sierung der moral so ähnlich wie die
anderen funktionen die ich vorhin
beschrieben habe wiederum symptome der
unmoral produziert nämlich das recht des
stärkeren nämlich das recht des
stärkeren argumente
das recht des stärkeren argument würde
bedeuten wir sind in der wissenschaft
wenn es gut läuft daran gewöhnt unsere
eigenen einstellungen zu verändern wenn
wir an uns selber wahrnehmen dass ein
argument das wir gebraucht haben sich
als falsch erwiesen hat ich weiß dass
das eine idealistische vorstellung ist
aber sie ist zumindest mit der funktion
der ausdifferenzierung des
wissenschaftlichen unmittelbar verwoben
also die schlimmsten formen von
wissenschaft sind die die man kennt wo
die leute sozusagen erstarrte und sich
als falsch herausgestellt
theorien noch so lange tot reiten bis
sie emeritiert werden
das symptom der unmoral das recht des
stärkeren argument zu formulieren findet
man aus soziologischer perspektive sehr
oft dort wo ethik in gremien form
umgesetzt wird und darüber würde ich
jemandem sechsten punkt jetzt sprechen
bevor allerdings nicht bevor ich in
paris noch einen satz zum verhältnis von
moral und recht gesagt habe das
verhältnis von moral und rechtes
außerordentlich komplex das verhältnis
von moral und recht ist insofern komplex
als die wichtigsten rechtlichen
vorschriften die wir kennen falsch die
wichtigsten rechtlichen grundlagen vor
allem die quellen des rechts ethischer
und moralischer natur sind also etwa die
tatsache dass wir gleiches gleich
behandeln sollen
oder die tatsache dass es vor dem gesetz
keine informationen über individuen
braucht um sie als rechtsfähige subjekte
anerkennen zu können also die
informations losigkeit des rechts dem
individuum gegenüber ist eine normative
setzung die historisch auch anders
möglich wäre wäre quatsch war
diese idee diese moral wird sozusagen
sowohl verschärft als auch entschärft
dadurch dass die funktion des rechts
normative erwartungs sicherheit nicht
nur theoretisch zu formulieren sondern
empirisch durchzusetzen
eine ganz interessante form ist in der
wir mit asymmetrie womöglich besser
umgehen können weil wir es in einer
verfahrens form bringen wiederum noch
eine parente in der parente das
interessanteste eigentlich am recht für
den soziologen ist das bisweilen recht
durchgesetzt wird das den intentionen
derer die dieses recht durchsetzen
widerspricht weil es aus normativen
gründen nicht anders geht ein schönes
beispiel ist die frage ob eigentlich
türkische und italienische gastarbeiter
die deutschland verlassen um ihre rente
am mittelmeer zu verbringen
die gleichen leistungen bekommen wie
diejenigen die in deutschland geblieben
sind und man hat zunächst mal gedacht
nun brauchen die da nächstes ist alles
billiger und das wetter ist besser oder
irgend sowas
und dann hat das recht so zu sagen an
sich selber beobachtet dass es nur
konsistent bleiben kann wenn sie gar
nicht sieht ob es sich um italiener oder
türken handle sondern um leute und
sozusagen eine art von normative
erwartungs sicherheit erzeugt die auf
den algorithmus guter gründe in der form
gar nicht mehr angewiesen war sondern
auf entscheidungen sechster punkt was
wir zurzeit beobachten ich habe von der
gremien ethik gesprochen das ist eine
ehrung des grundmechanismus der moral in
der kommunikation wie ich sie in meinem
zweiten punkt dargestellt habe wir haben
selber ein forschungsprojekt gemacht
über klinischer ethikkomitees und haben
darin beobachtet wie schwierig es für
solche komitees ist ethische expertise
umzusetzen
es ist ganz interessant dass in diesen
komitees kaum ethiker sitzen und zwar
nicht deshalb weil die keine zeit dafür
hätten sondern weil man mit denen da
eigentlich nicht viel anfangen kann und
zwar deswegen weil ethiker probleme des
typs lösen ich übertreibe jetzt ein
bisschen in diesem fall in dem es um den
suizid eines patienten in einem
krankenhaus geht hätte man aus einer
tugend ethischen perspektive anders
reagieren müssen
der theologische so simpel argumentiert
niemand aber ich will nur den typus von
kommunikation beschreiben der als
ethischer perspektive eine
außerordentlich wichtige frage ist aber
in diesen gremien eigentlich keine
wirkliche rolle spielt in den klinischen
ethikkomitees das nicht zu verwechseln
übrigens mit mit ethikkommissionen die
mit forschung und ähnlichem zu tun haben
oder lebensspende kommissionen oder
solchen geschichten da ging es
hauptsächlich darum strittige fälle im
krankenhaus durch unterschiedliche
professionell handeln die im krankenhaus
arbeiten in einer künstlich auf
augenhöhe gebrachten form von
kommunikation zu diskutieren da haben
sie zum beispiel die situation dass bei
einem angekündigten suizid eines
patienten der dann tatsächlich
stattgefunden hat auch von einem
somatischen mediziner andere sätze
gesagt werden als von einem psychiater
der somatische mediziner sagt für einen
suizid gab es gar kein grund so krank
war der gar nicht für ein psychiater
wäre sozusagen die frage wenn jemand
ankündigt sich sowie zitieren zu wollen
ist das pathologisches verhalten man
hätte personen also sedieren müssen
woraufhin der jurist natürlich als
natürlicher feind des arztes und des
psychiaters im besonderen natürlich sagt
moment dass suizid ist nicht strafbar
das ist eine freie entscheidung eine
rechtsperson da kann man nicht einfach
so eindringen auf der perspektive des
pflegepersonals hinweis auf die falsche
organisation des krankenhauses mit zu
kurzen kontaktzeiten dem patienten
gegenüber
aus der perspektive der seelsorge
falsche kommunikationsform und so weiter
interessant ist immer die perspektive
der verwaltungs des verwaltungschefs
eines krankenhauses der sagt alles schön
und gut was sich akademiker hier vor
euch hin redet aber wir dürfen nicht
noch einmal mit so einem thema in die
presse kommen weil ich sonst die betten
nicht vollkriegen euro löhne nicht sein
kann und das interessante ist dass diese
unterschiedlichen perspektiven ja alle
ihr recht haben dann hat keiner hat
recht und keine hat unrecht sondern sie
haben sozusagen eine form zu entwickeln
zu entscheidungen zu kommen und zum teil
sogar zu gemeinsamen entscheidungen zu
kommen das interessante ist was wir
empirisch beobachtet haben dass sich
darin einerseits eine funktional
differenzierte gesellschaft zeigt wir
sind daran gewöhnt dass aus
unterschiedlichen professionellen
perspektiven unterschiedliche nicht
wahrheiten das hat nichts mit einem
bereits begriff zu tun sondern
unterschiedliche perspektiven gelten wir
haben andererseits herausgefunden wie
ethisch plausibel es ist wenigstens
zeitweise in einer hochgradig
hierarchisch organisierten
organisationen wie dem krankenhaus auf
augenhöhe zu reden
man könnte auch sagen achtungs und
missachtung management zu machen was
mich mit am meisten berührt das sind so
setzte von von pflegepersonal die dann
sagen sie haben das erste mal gesehen
dass auch chefärzte entscheidungen
treffen müssen und entscheidung sind ja
bekannterweise nur dann zu treffen wenn
man nicht hundertprozentig weiß was man
tun muss
aber wenn es auch andere möglichkeiten
gäbe das haben sie sich als wird sagen
subalterne beobachter eines einer elite
position vorher gar nicht vorstellen
können also man könnte sagen
hier entsteht auf einmal achtung für
eine position die vorher immer im
zweifel stand weil sie ja auf einmal
jemand ist der im gleichen kontingenten
steht wie man selber das ist ethisch
noch relativ leicht zu rekonstruieren
das interessanteste argument das
verdanken wir in unserer forschergruppe
vor allem im wird sage das ist dass die
kohärenz des gesprächs innerhalb einer
solchen gremiums die kohärenz ethische
argumente ersetzt
es kommt vor allem darauf an achtung zu
universalisierung eine simulation von
augenhöhe herzustellen
bei der das moral schema der
kommunikation nämlich achtung stark zu
machen
jegliche sachliche asymmetrie
unplausibel werden lässt sachlicher
asymmetrie im sinne der unmoral des
besseren arguments das dem anderen
darstellen muss dass ein schlechteres
argument asymmetrie produzieren muss
das heißt das können wir an vielen
stellen beobachten dass wir dort wo
nicht wissenschaftlich tätig stattfindet
wurde sondern wurde sondern wo die
ethnisierung von problemen stattfindet
wir uns damit begnügen augenhöhe
herzustellen
unabhängig von sachlichen argumenten
das gilt für partizipative forschung ja
wo sozusagen der beforscht zum forscher
erklärt wird das gilt für
multikulturalität es ist unglaublich
schwierig in dieser gesellschaft im
kontext von multikulturalität zu
diskutieren und gleichzeitig eine
asymmetrie von zivilisatorischen
standards zu betonen die ist ja
offenkundig gibt ganz ganz schwer
also diese differenzen sozusagen nicht
nur als differenzen als asymmetrien zu
zu beschreiben das funktioniert fast
nicht selbst wenn man bessere gründe hat
er mit sagte wird in ihrer habilitation
sehr schön zeigen wie jürgen habermas
idee des zwanglosen zwangs des besseren
arguments empirisch letztlich dazu führt
zu zwanglosen kommunikation ohne
argumente weil argumente letztlich nur
etwas sind was für professionell
handelnde dann ins wissenschaftssystem
zurückgedrängt wird und das scheint mir
auch die die große differenz zu sein ja
zwischen wenn man normative fragen rede
zwischen sozusagen einer
wissenschaftlichen ethik und ihrer und
schon der begriff den ich verwende ist
falsch durchsetzbarkeit praxisfelder ich
bin dass es bei diesen andeutung und
kommt zu beim siebten und letzten punkt
den ich eine moralische oder normative
intuition genannt habe diesen begriff
der minimal moral in der kommunikation
den kann man nicht nur empirisch meinen
sondern er hat durchaus auch eine
normative komponente der hat nämlich die
normative komponente zeigen zu können
dass wenn wir tatsächlich normative
standards stark machen wollen in einer
gesellschaft von sprechern die nicht
mehr daran gewöhnt ist wie an einer
strategie zierten gesellschaft oder
einer bürgerlichen gesellschaft mit
autoritativen sprechern denen wir nicht
widersprechen können tatsächlich selber
zu sprechen
dann müssen wir formen finden wie wir
tatsächlich asymmetrien in die
kommunikation hinein bringen können
eine dieser formen haben können wir aus
dem rechtssystem lernen nämlich die form
der mediation die mediation die in
amerika vor allem zunächst einmal beim
thema der ehescheidung begonnen hat
inzwischen in fast allen rechts feldern
anwendung findet die mediation hat
zunächst einmal den tieferen sinn einen
konsens über den dissens herzustellen
also seine idee davon zu vermitteln
warum man eigentlich aus
unterschiedlichen perspektiven auf das
gleiche phänomen guckt das kann man
nicht sozusagen per ordre einer
professionell instanz tun sondern es
muss innerhalb der kommunikation
geschehen würde aus meiner sicht eher
theoretischen perspektive die idee der
sprach pragmatik von habermas sehr stark
machen habe was sagt das für mich ein
sehr plausibel in gedanken dass in einem
zwanglosen diskurs als edf als idee
nicht argumente vorgetragen werden die
schon da sind sondern sich die argumente
in der praxis selber formen
ich glaube das ist auch etwas was man an
sich selber empirisch beobachten kann
man kommt oftmals auf ideen erst dann
wenn man auf die gegen idee eines
gegenübers reagieren muss uns erklären
uns dass die hirnforscher heute ist ganz
ganz interessant zu sagen dass bestimmte
internationalistische handlungs modelle
die wir so im kopf haben auch als
alltags theorien womöglich zu kurz
greifen dass wir in situationen
auf das richtige kommen wie zb in
unserer muttersprache gesprochen
brauchen wir selten internationalität im
sinne sozusagen einer entschuldung einer
bewusstheit dessen was wir sagen wollen
in unserem bewusstsein sondern das
geschieht in praxi das wäre mit einem
hd+ begriff vom brutto oder auch
womöglich sogar mit mit der russe mit
dem hochdeutschen begriff der ur
impression all i tät von gegen warten
und retention ahlen und professionellen
prozessen im bewusstsein durchaus
kompatibel und ich das will ich jetzt
nicht sozusagen ein bis ins einzelne
durch diskutieren aber ich glaube dass
diese art von institutionalisieren von
kommunikations situationen in denen wir
situationen herstellen in denen wir das
potenzial von kommunikation achtung auch
dort herzustellen wo differenzen sind
nicht um einfach nur achtung
herzustellen sondern zu anderen formen
von argumentation zu kommen nicht ganz
unwichtig sind die unbedingtheit von
achtungs bedingungen was ja eine
paradoxe formulierung ist die
unbedingtheit von achtungs bedingungen
ist ja etwas was wir in der
rekonstruktion der normativität der
westlichen moderne formulieren können ja
letztlich bis in unsere grundlegenden
rechtsformen immer schon eingang
gefunden hat also die grundlegende
rechtsform die das westliche die
westlichen demokratien kennen ist
tatsächlich dass ich will das mal auf
die formel bringen niemand
zurückgelassen werden darf herr wiederum
sie haben wir haben frankfurt mal
zusammen so einer spd veranstaltung
gemacht da haben sie die den grund die
die nord normative idee der
sozialdemokratie sozusagen sehr weit
zurück datiert und im prinzip genau mit
dem argument dass man mit der also weit
zurück datiert heißt bis in die stör und
mit dem argument dass man sozusagen auf
die idee kommen muss wenn man eine
minimal moral im sinne sozusagen einer
die jetzt gar nicht auf inhaltliche
spezifikationen aus ist sondern auf die
grundlage dessen auf die wir normative
scheidungen aufbauen formulieren will
dann bleibt am ende nur übrig ich nehme
meine formel dass keiner zurück gelassen
werden darf heißt dass der gleiche wert
von allen in einer gesellschaft die den
menschen ungleiche positionen
notwendigerweise zuweist vorgesehen
werden muss das ist in einem anderen
kulturellen kontext womöglich in
plausibel
das können wir letztlich schon an
unserer eigenen geschichte und ich es
ist bei sowas immer sehr wichtig wenn
ich von psychiatrischen standards rede
nicht andere kulturen zu sehen sondern
die eigene geschichte nur unter großen
schmerzen durchsetzbar bis in die
paradoxie hinein dass wir in einer
gesellschaft in der wir alles allgemeine
landrecht wann war das 1797 einführen
ein junger von heute auf gleich auf
augenhöhe mit seinem früheren knecht ist
und beide damit klarkommen dass sich
wohlgemerkt beide ist es für beide
unglaublich schwierig gewesen
das heißt übrigens nicht dass dieses
recht zur universal war dass man
bestimmte gruppen in der gesellschaft
dass die gleiche augenhöhe sozusagen
schon gegeben hätte denn die juden hat
man lange draußen vor gelassen fühlen
öffentlichen dienst für die
universitäten und ähnliches was dann
dazu geführt hat dass die meisten juden
protestantisches sich haben taufen
lassen wie zum beispiel die familie von
mendelssohn bartholdy und trotzdem einen
text wie wagner dann geschrieben werden
konnte vielleicht ich trotzdem sondern
sogar gerade deshalb weil das die
besonders perfide strategie war die
ununterscheidbarkeit herzustellen aber
diese normative idee scheint im hinblick
auf die konsistenz der sauberkeit einer
gesellschaft ohne dass man sich selber
dem risiko der missachtung aussetzt
operativ geradezu notwendig zu sein
vielleicht muss die ethik deshalb
stärker den kontakt zu einer soziologie
suchen die nicht sozusagen ethisch
völlig unmusikalisch ist oder normativ
völlig unmusikalisch also im hinblick
darauf dass es sich nur dafür
interessiert welche normativen standards
eigentlich wo empirisch auftreten
sondern zu einer die versucht zu zeigen
dass soziale systeme gar nicht anders
können als für den andern also für
und alter ego immer schon einen platz
für anschlussfähigkeit herzustellen die
minimal moral von kommunikation führt
dann zu einem merkwürdigerweise
anthropologischen argument nämlich dem
anthropologischen argument dass wir
schon in der kommunikation
trotz der totalen informations losigkeit
demgegenüber gegenüber so etwas wie wird
das sind formulierung von massa nußbaum
vielleicht grund befähigungen und
grunderfahrungen nicht unbedingt
theoretisch voraussetzen müssen aber
immer schon sozusagen voraussetzen also
nicht nicht sozusagen voraussetzen im
sinne sozusagen eine explizit hat aber
immer schon implizit voraussetzen sonst
werde die zurechnungsfähigkeit des
anderen in sozialen systemen gar nicht
gegeben vielleicht wird es irgendwann
sogar gelingen dass der zwanglose zwang
des besseren arguments nicht mehr
ethisch